Transcriber: Dusum Su
Gözden geçirme: Ilayda Gokgoz
Sevgili gençler, merhaba,
hepiniz hoş geldiniz.
İsmi Göksel Gülensoy.
Yapımcı ve yönetmenim.
Benim hayalim ve hayallerim
çocukluğumda başladı aslında.
Bizim dönemimizde şimdiki gibi
dijital dünya yoktu sinemalar vardı.
Hatta ve hatta yazlık sinemalar vardı.
Tek eğlencemiz ailemle birlikte
hafta sonları o sinemalara gitmek
o sinemalarda filmleri seyretmek.
Ama ben maalesef
beyaz perdeye hiç bakmadım.
Daha doğrusu arkamdan gelen sinema
makinesinden çıkan o ışığın o
projeksiyonunu peşinden koştum
hayatım boyunca.
Aklımdan hep o odaya girmenin
yollarını araştırdım.
Makine dairesine ve işte
ilkokul bitti, ortaokul bitti.
Ortaokulda da bizim dönemimizde
16 milimetrelik filmler oynatılırdı.
Sabahçılar ve öğlenciler olmak suretiyle
arada sırada sinema makinelerinden
filmler gösterilirdi 16 milimetrelik.
Tabii ben filmi hiçbir zaman seyretmedim.
Okulumuza gelen o projeksiyon makinesine
ve o projeksiyon makinesinin nasıl
çalıştığını merak ettim
ve sinema makinası ehliyeti
almam gerekiyordu.
Bunun için de bizim dönemimizde liseyi
bitirdiği zaman üniversite sayılıyordu.
Ben de liseyi endüstri meslek lisesinde
bitirdim ve hatta ve hatta
elektrik bölümünü de bitirmem lazımdı.
Sinema makinistliği ehliyetini alabilmem
için mezun olduktan sonra hemen
belediyeye başvurdum ve profesyonel
olarak sinema makinesi ehliyetini
almıştım.
İkinci bir hedef kafamda koydum bu
filmler nerede, nasıl çekiliyordu.
Onu çok merak ediyordum.
Filmlerin Yeşilçam'dan geldiğini, o
dönemde Yeşilçam'da büyük bir sektör
olduğunu, Türk sinemasının tüm filmlerinin
orada çekildiğini öğrendim
ve bir gün atladım Beyoğlu’na,
gittim Yeşilçam’a.
Lise çağlarında, makine dairelerinde
çalıştığım dönemlerde öğrenmiştim.
Yönetmen bir filmi çekiyordu ve hedefini
ben o dönemde koymuştum.
Lise bittikten sonra ve ben
yönetmen olmak istiyordum.
Bunun için de yapmam gereken
en önemli şey
bir yönetmenin asistanı olarak başlamaktı,
ben de o dönemde bu filmlerin çekildiği
Türk sinemasını döneminde benimde çok
böyle keyif aldığım ve bana rehberlik
yapan iki usta ile birlikte çalıştığım
Ertem Eğilmez ve Metin Erksan, Halit
Refiğ gibi ustalarla çalıştım
ve artık yavaş yavaş
bu dünyanın içine girmiştim.
Makine dairelerinden Yeşilçam’a,
Yeşilçam’dan da bu kamera önünde
oyuncularla birlikte çalıştığım
dönem başlamıştı.
Bizim dönemimizde ne yazık ki bu kadar
çok sinema televizyon okulu da yoktu.
Usta çırak ilişkisi bizim
için çok önemliydi.
Ustamız derdi ki; Hadi Göksel
hazırsın, bu filmi de sen çek.
Artık o noktaya gelmiştim.
Türk sinemasında tam 15 yıl
bir kara film çekilmedi.
Bu beni çok etkiledi.
Çünkü COVID gibi 1 yıl, 2 yıl gibi
bir süre değildi benim için.
Tam 15 yıl ve özellikle aslında benim için
çok kara bir dönem başladı
ve bu kara dönemden sonra da
ne yapmam gerektiğini bilmiyordum
ve TRT’ye başvurdum.
TRT'ye girdim.
TRT'ye girdikten sonra da kendimi
o dönemde geliştirmeye başladım.
Eğer sinema çekilmiyorsa,
ben TRT’de program yapacağım.
Programlar yapacağım, belgeseller
çekeceğim diye.
Nitekim de öyle oldu.
TRT'ye girdim.
TRT’ye girdikten sonra bir çok belgesel
çekmeye başladım ama bu
arada da Yeşilçam’dan
ustam Metin Erksan’la orada hayatımız
tekrar kesişti ve orada da Metin Hocam,
ışıklar içinde uyusun,
bana şey demişti.
Göksel öyle iş yap ki
yaptığın her iş, belgesel,
beş kitap kadar değerli olsun.
Yazacağın beş kitap kadar değerli olsun
diye bir cümle sarf etmişti bana.
Ben de bunun ne olduğunu anlamadım.
Ama zaman içerisinde ilk filmimi
çektiğimde 1994 yılında
Ayasofya ile ilgili.
Justinianus bir imparator olarak kazandığı
askeri başarılardan çok
İstanbul’a kazandırdığı ölümsüz uygarlık
anıtlarıyla ünlenmiştir.
Justinianus devrinde İstanbul köprüler,
kiliseler, çarşılar
ve su kemerleri ile dolmuştur.
1994 yılında yaptığım bu belgesel
uluslararası birçok ödülü aldı.
Bir hedefe daha yaklaşmıştım.
Çünkü bu hedefim benim için çok önemliydi.
Artık bir yönetmen kimliğiyle çıkmıştım
1994′te bütün toplumdaki seyirci önüne
ve ilk yönetmen olarak orada anıldım kendi
filmini çektikten sonra ve tabii ki daha
büyük bir zevk aldım.
Bir yönetmen kelimesi ve hedefe
ulaştığında bir yönetmen kelimesinin
bu kadar beni nerelere sürüklediğini
şimdi daha iyi anlıyorum.
Çünkü yaptığım işlerde her zaman
şunu kendimde benimsedim.
Göksel kendine bir hedef koy.
O hedefte onu yap ve ondan
sonra gömleğini çıkar.
Çıkardıktan sonra orada ne yaptın?
Hatalarım neydiyi birebir
o gömlekle yüzleşirdim.
Yani ben bu filmi çektiğimde
o filmde ne hatalar yaptığımı
kendimle aynaya bakarak yüzleşirdim.
Aslında tek rakibim vardı kendimdi
ve zamanla bu değişti.
Filmler, filmler, filmler derken
Ayasofya’nın Derinliklerinde diye
bir projede çalışmaya başladım.
Bu proje de benim için çok
çok önemli bir projeydi.
Ayasofya’nın altındaki tünelleri
araştırıyorduk, biliyorsunuz
Roma, Bizans döneminin
İstanbul’un altındaki
ayrı bir şehirdi o dönem.
Onun dışında burası tehlikeli bir yer
çünkü...
hayatınız boyunca bazı belgeseller vardır,
çok uğraşırsınız üzerinde ama bu
uğraştığınız zaman, zaman o kadar çok akar
ki siz doğru bir işi yapıp yapmadığınız
endişesine kapılırsınız.
Bu endişe zaman içerisinde büyür.
Ben de bu projeyi yaparken böyle
bir endişeye kapıldım
ve hala da üzerinde çalışıyoruz.
Fakat bir an öyle bir an geldi
ki bir sabah uyandım.
Uyandığımda bir arkadaşımın telefonuyla
dedi ki Göksel dedi.
Dan Brown’ın kitabını aldın mı?
Yoo dedim, anladım.
Dan Brown kitabında
senden bahsediyor dedi.
Allah Allah dedim.
Şaşırdım çünkü
hani dünyanın en büyük yazarlarından bir
tanesi Dan Brown Inferno kitabında...
Yani şunda.
Bu kitapta seksen dördüncü bölümü
açtığınızda benden bahsediyordu.
Çok şaşırmıştım ve doğru bir iş yaptığımın
arkasındaydım ve bu da benim için
çok büyük bir onur kaynağı oldu ve bana
çok büyük bir motivasyon oldu.
Bu kitapta yer almaktan dolayı
çok mutlu oldum.
Ayasofya’nın Derinliklerinde şu
anda yapım aşamasında bitti.
Fakat Ayasofya’yı yaparken ben başka
bir projeyle devam ediyordum.
Sadan Hanım projesi,
alzaymır hastası bir kadının hafıza
kaybının hikayesini anlattım.
Projeyi dört yılda realize ettim,
gerçekleştirdim.
Bugün günlerden ne söyler misiniz?
Cuma.
1900′lerde miyiz, 2000′lerde miyiz?
Neredeyiz?
Söylesene Göksel!
İnsan öleceğini de bilir
ama asla kondurmaz.
Alzheimer olmak da benzer bir şey,
hayatın sizi ne zaman nereye
sürükleyeceği belli olmuyor.
Ta ki hayatın gerçek yüzüyle
tanışana dek.
Sadan Hanım projesinin çekimleri bittikten
sonra hepimizin bildiği Kovid
denilen o lanet salgın hayatımıza girdi ve
tabii hayatımıza girmesiyle kalmadı
bir de hepimizi evlerimize mahkum etti.
Bir yönetmen olarak bir film
bitiriyorsunuz ama filmini
sergileyemiyorsunuz ve o süreç geçen 2 yıl
inanın sizin kadar beni de mahvetti.
Çünkü hayallerinizin peşinden koşup
bi film yapıp o filmin sonucunu alamadan
sanki hayatımı yarıda kalmış gibi böyle
kendimi bir böyle içime kapattım.
Eve kapandığında, kendiniz de kaldığınızda
ve geleceğiniz ile ilgili ve
filmle ilgili o kadar önemli kararlar
alıyorsunuz ki aslında komitenin bir de
bazı böyle kötü olayların iyi
tarafına bakmak gerekiyor.
Ben de Kovid meselesinin
iyi tarafına yönelmiş,
evde Sadan Hanım’la ilgili gelecekte
ne yapacağının projesini realize ettim,
gerçekleştirdim.
Nitekim de Kovid bitti, arkasından
filminin galası yapıldı.
Şimdi film festivallerde yarışıyor.
Sizin bu süreçteki kararlılığımız, bu
süreçteki ne yapacağınız, bu süreçteki ne
yapmak istediğimiz de doğru orantılı .
Bir dönem bu hem benim için hem sizin
için çok önemli bir dönem aslında.
Sizlerin de mutlaka hayalleri vardır.
Hayalin peşinden koşmak kadar güzel bir
şey yoktur aslında ama bundan sonra da
dünyanın başına ne gelecek?
Bundan sonra dünyada ne olacak?
Kovid gibi sizler de ben de hepimiz
yaşayarak göreceğiz.
Ama ne olursa olsun önemli olan
sizin kendi hedeflerinizden
asla ve asla şaşmamanız.
Hatta şimdi şöyle güzel bir söz geldi
aklıma.
İçimizin derinliklerinde
bizim oraya koyduklarımızdan
başka bir şey yoktur.
Aslında siz kendi içinize ne koyarsanız
koyun, o içimizdeki ile büyüyün ve
içimizdeki yaptığınız hayallerle sonsuza
dek yaşayan eserlerimizi bırakın,
hedeflerimizin seçin.
Ama hayal kurmayı ve kurduğumuz
hayallerinin peşinden koşmayı
asla ve asla bırakmayın.
Teşekkür ederim.